[Applause]
[Music]
let's talk about the kind of spear
you're going to need for
training so we're training with a
japanese style spear let me show you
traditional japanese style spear
so this is a traditional japanese style
spear and it's more elaborate than
what we're going to work with and also
it's this is a battlefield sphere so
this sphere is seven feet tall
this is a medium-sized spear for the
battlefield and not what we're going to
generally be using for iq to practice
although you could do all the actions
we do with this size spear it's just not
really what you're looking for
and especially in a training situation
when you're training with partners
this wouldn't be very good now this to
maybe take out and have a bale of hay
or something that you stick it in
repeatedly that might be good to to do
something with this
but this is not the kind of spear we're
generally going to be using for this
practice
now we could use a metal tipped sphere
here so this is i made these i don't
think they're commercially available but
they're not too hard to make
um so i just fashioned a sankaku yachty
head which is a triangular shaped yachty
head
this one's made out of aluminum because
it doesn't need to cut anything or put
up with a ton of riggers
and so uh we made these and used these
for a long time
and they're great because you definitely
can see that the spearhead's there and
how the spearhead would be working and
if you were trying to learn anything
about working with the edges you could
see where the edges were
and that's great the problem with
training with these uh spear
on spear and anything besides uh cebudi
and solo forms
is that um these will chew the heck out
of the
the spear shafts so um this one's got
some some nice nicks in it and the other
ones we use against it
um the the spear tip will catch these
shafts over and over and over
and they'll knock big chunks out of it
so you'll have to replace the shaft a
lot that's a lot of work because this is
made in a somewhat traditional fashion
where there's a makugi uh uh rat tail a
tang
that goes down inside the shaft and so
the shaft has to be hollowed out and
then it's cut in a square because if it
was in a circle it would spin
it's cutting a square and then you have
to to fit the head perfectly to it so
it's a lot of work
so busting the shaft is no fun um and so
while these are really cool and they're
great for cebu
and solo practice i wouldn't do a whole
lot of spear on spear stuff with these
now there are wooden alternatives right
so this one
this one comes from scuba mountain in
japan um and is
probably the exact replica of the kind
of spear that yuishi would use or
a similar one that he might have used
saito sensei uh used spears like this so
this is really nice this is uh got four
heads on us it's a different style of
spear but this would work really great
for sheer practice it's awesome
the problem with this is again this will
take damage so these fine little tips
get knocked around i don't use this this
one uh
here because these can't be made anymore
for anything other than solo form so
when i'm going through solo forms i'll
use this because it's kind of fun
now one of my students had um
kingfisher woodworks come up with some
of these for us to practice with and
these are great i think these are still
available
at kingfisher woodworks and so this is
great but again while this would be
really good for solo work
this tip is likely to get broken and
we've already broken a few tips and some
are splintered this one's got a couple
weird spots in it because these these
fine little points are going to get
knocked around really hard by the shafts
of the other sphere
and they just don't put up with a lot of
abuse so this is a great thing
for practicing sabudi or any kind of
solo work
but um to actually hit another spear
with these aren't really a great thing
to use
but they are commercially available and
they're fun to have and they're nice and
and they're cool to look at and cool to
do
forms with this
is what we use for all of our spear on
spear action
and it's just a joke that we taped the
end up now
we taped this so that way you always
know where your spear tip would be so
that black tape lets you know where your
spear tip would be
this is also a cheap way to introduce
people to spear so if you have a joe
put a piece of tape on it if your dojo
has a bunch of joes
put some tape on them right so if you
look at our videos of us doing joe work
almost all of our joes now have a piece
of tape on them so you can use them as a
spear or use them as a joe
also because it's just a joe there's no
head that's particularly damaging the
other shafts and no fragile parts to get
broken
and this basically serves the purpose so
you can do most all of the work for the
spear on spear stuff
with these that said we occasionally do
break out the other ones but we just
don't do it that much with them because
they take a lot of damage that way so
i would recommend especially just
starting out get your joes put a piece
of tape on the end
and that's a good way to start training
spear and then as you want to move up
you can either make your own spheres or
you can have some made for you
um or there's some commercially
available kingfisher woodworks has those
spears still available i believe
um so that's a good way to go so don't
let the equipment stop you it's as
simple as get a joe put a piece of tape
on the end and you can start doing
spear work i'm christopher hine thanks a
[Music]
lot